foreign
an army bro you muted
bro I was telling myself the whole time
I'm not gonna do that and then I ended
up doing it wrong it's all good but so
now I got on top of the couch and
welcome back to this podcast in the
Dunya the Muslims quick note today
Arnold could not join us unfortunately
he might not be able to just for a few
weeks but he will be back uh I think for
Saturday streams it's just the one that
sounds can't make sure Allah so today we
got with us brother Jad if you recognize
him you've probably seen him on the
Jubilee video where he went and he
crushed it he won sorry
the uh the uh I don't want to say any
offensive terms but the I'll just call
them the Liberals the liberal Muslims
people will claim these egregious things
about Islam he went and he shot them
down in the Halal alhamdulillah welcome
to the podcast bro how you doing today
appreciate it I mean thank you guys for
having me on it's always an honor uh
thank you very excited to be here
love your energy bro this is our first
time meeting I know well we missed the
last time Michelle I was looking forward
to meeting you
it's been a couple months and uh
Abdullah I think uh stronger and better
and uh there's no better time than
alhamdulillah
we uh already started starting with
these comments Rami and Jad are 20.
every time bro yeah if I took off my hot
bro we'd be 20 even more I'm I'm pretty
bald like you yeah
all right so um
if you guys have heard the news
um or if you haven't Charlotte don't
worry you'll hear it here today
you've probably heard of him probably
seen him around
um there's been some news going around
about him he's been caught doing
something that some people think is uh a
little crazy so inshallah we're gonna
play the video and then discuss it
[Music]
oh
so as you can see
as you can see here
he is praying a Salah and in praying his
Salah he looked around and he like you
know push His Garment a little bit and
all this stuff and let's let's let's put
it on the screen one more time
look look at the caption look what it
says I hope he got no mentally
what the heck is wrong with people man
metal caption is crazy yeah people
people have issues I know people don't
like
um
okay no worries we're really really
really yeah there are people that that
don't like him for some reason but
listen listen at the end of the day and
this is Tick Tock it might be a kid or
something
this person out of the way to screen
records live stream just to be able to
clip it up and make him look like what
like a tired person someone who's tired
who prayed away who maybe was teaching
all day or working all day and he's
fasting and maybe he's praying clam now
the guy is tired what is wrong with you
people the man is tired
and
you hope he has no mental issues like
what is this bro this is messed up and
actually I think it digs into this this
bigger problem that a lot of Muslims in
the community have which is they're just
waiting to find a little bit of a mess
up from someone so they can amplify and
they can make somebody look bad yeah
okay you don't like someone no worries
but you're going out of your way
to try and and make them look bad to try
and do literally praying for their
downfall like what did you expect to get
out of this video everyone's gonna say
oh he's whack he's fake look he's not
even praying stuff with a lot of Liam
bro the guy is clearly tired I think a
lot of people have a disease in their
heart to be completely honest but what
do you guys think
um I think you're right and this is part
of a bigger issue that
something you notice a lot especially in
the Muslim Community which is
unfortunate that all these
um Scholars or anyone who's a public
figure as a Muslim
unfortunately the Muslim Community
rather than waiting for you rather than
looking to cover your mistakes or trying
to be supportive they're waiting on you
to make a mistake at any given moment
just like everyone else is waiting on
all these celebrities and whatever to
make a mistake just so they can cancel
them quote unquote cancel them bring
them down and um it's unfortunate that
rather than seeing this where we're told
as we notice Allah always said give the
best of um and you're supposed to
give your brother the best um
blanking
um
what do you call it assumption
assumption yeah so assume the best of
your brother yeah exactly you always
assume the best of your brother or
sister and unfortunately that's not
something that we practice we always see
someone and we always assume the worst
the second we see someone doing
something questionable or something that
we don't think looks right so it's
it's frustrating
um I'm sure you guys have experienced
some sort of experience like this where
you do something that maybe looks wrong
and no one gives you
um the good assumption they always
assume the worst right away
uh something that really as a Muslim
Community it's really frustrating and
I don't know I don't know how we can fix
it but inshallah we can yeah bro I agree
there's two main issues I fall one is
what you said where people are kind of
losing sight of assuming the best of
your brother and covering up for one
another's slips and downfalls and just
being human bro at the end of the day
because no one's perfect including a
Sheikh including an Alim or an Imam or
anyone like that
but the number two
to then share it on social media bro
people don't realize it how sinful that
is
and I believe there's a Hadith where the
Prophet saw mentions that everyone will
be for forgiven you know on that day
except those that are going to be
exposing one another's sins and
including their own sins and putting it
for everyone else to see bro
so I don't know if that's the person
that made that that caption I really
don't but someone was recording that in
the Masjid
it's probably a Muslim right I don't
really think non-muslims are going to
tell away of all prayers
and putting that on bro it's disgusting
bro
yeah 100 I think it was from a live
stream so maybe the Imam himself or
someone just just put up
um to stream it but uh the issue is a
person who you know chops it up and and
posts in that way
um I think well first let me say um it's
a very beautiful Hadith he said if you
see alcohol dripping from the beer to
your brother you should assume that
somebody spilled it on him just think
about that you you walk in the street
and you see someone you recognize him
see alcohol from their beard I'll call
dripping from their beard
and everyone's gonna assume why he's
been drinking and he's you know maybe
he's really drunk because now it's in
his beard as well you know he can't even
drink normally
um who said that we should assume that
somebody went up to him listen how crazy
it sounds someone one of them and
spilled on him
like subhanallah but that's the level of
of love and respect that we have to have
for our brothers we have to like you
said assume the best in our brothers
especially those who you know teach
Islam they go out of their way and I'm
not talking about like people like
myself and like the three of us up here
he's like a different level you know he
is learning he's study at the University
of Medina he's teaching Islam and as
well on his way I think to maybe
becoming
but yeah and he does so much work and he
actually made a video on this uh on this
topic about like April Fools and joking
and all that stuff and
kind of mocking people or whatever and
inshallah he actually shared a few of
the points with me he said there are
seven conditions of joking
and um he he said that it would be good
inshallah to share these so I'm going to
go through them quickly so firstly
you cannot be mocking the dean when
you're joking you cannot be not mocking
Islam a lot of people make the honestly
horrendous jokes about like stealing
from the Masjid and you know mocking
Allah in his messenger and the verses
from the Quran and all these things like
and they think they're being funny
no and I believe there's an eye in the
Quran you know was it Allah in his
messenger who you were mocking or was it
Allah in the signs that you were mocking
something along that line
subhanallah imagine being on the day of
judgment Allah asks you that man may
Allah protect us the second condition
is that you cannot be mocking people
you can't be mocking people especially
it would be even worse if you're mocking
like their facial features or their body
or how they look because you're
basically indirectly insulting Allah
because Allah has created that person
exactly how they are
and even worse if the person is you know
righteous and loved by Allah imagine
somebody's loved by Allah and you're
going to be making fun of them man
another condition obviously is you
cannot be lying you can't sit there and
lie
um as a joke this is like 90 of the
jokes today they're like unfortunately
exaggerative or complete lies and all
that stuff you cannot scare people so
like I can't put a jump scare on the
screen and scare the whole audience
um otherwise maybe I would have Allah
Islam is saving you guys from a horrible
thing
um you cannot be too excessive
and you have to be able to do at the
right time yeah you can you should not
be joking with someone who's like you
know that maybe their father passed away
and you're going you're telling jokes or
something it's not the time to be in
that kind of mood and not imitating the
non-muslims of opposite gender as these
people have been cursed so these are the
seven conditions of joking now why am I
sharing this
not just because Abu Tamia asked me to
share but why did he ask me to share it
because he wanted to make it very clear
that it's okay for us to joke you know
we can joke about things
but there are certain conditions that
have to be met so we're not just boring
stale people we're allowed to be
light-hearted we're allowed to have fun
we're allowed to joke around but with
like everything in life with certain
guidelines you cannot transgress against
Allah and the people and you know the
religion that Allah has sent just for
the sake of getting a few laughs and
that's not an honorable thing either to
be completely honest
um but I want to give the floor to you
guys inshallah what do you think
um yeah I think it's something
especially now we're seeing once again
more and more on social media and I'll
see videos on Tick Tock like Muslim
content creators creating videos about
Islam joking about
the D making jokes about the dean and
things and it's really really
frustrating the level that it's gotten
to and like to make that video and not
think that you're doing anything wrong
it's really really sad
um there are some videos that you'll see
like some Muslim content creators they
do make some videos and they're funny
and I don't feel like they've crossed
the line then there's other ones where
they like they'll they'll associate
them or they'll say something in a
context that like it just doesn't seem
right like when you see you're just like
how did you think this was okay to post
like how did you think this is like
you're gonna be questioned about this
and I think a lot of people
unfortunately
um protect us all but unfortunately it's
like it is like I'm sure people are here
are saying like it is unfortunately for
the cloud like they know that these
certain things are gonna get views and
um some people are just willing to do
whatever it is whatever make whatever
joke is necessary to get the views and
they don't really they're not really
looking into the future they're just
seeing the short term right now and
they're not seeing the long-term results
of it so I ask Allah to protect us from
that and I don't want to be I don't want
to be a hypocrite of course
um but it's scary man it's scary and I I
think I've fallen into some of those
things as well with the joking thing I
need to I need to follow those seven
steps I think the lying thing is
probably the easiest thing to fall into
because when you're making a joke yeah
it's very easy to just you want to say
something funny so you just come up with
something on the spot
um so inshallah I need to work on I need
to work on a couple of those things
myself but yeah it's pretty scary man
inshallah um we could all work on that I
mean a little protect us bro I mean
people don't realize that cloud is kind
of like a drug bro when you have drugs
that in a way
put you in a state of heedlessness
towards
sobriety towards rational thinking
things that you wouldn't do when you're
not on that substance Club was the same
thing everyone does random things that
they can't imagine themselves doing bro
right when they're in a state of wanting
to get more followers or more viewers or
more whatever
you know I generally know people that in
a way get lost in the sauce and Muslim
influencers especially should be kind of
on their p's and q's because for us we
have to balance sincerity versus still
trying to level up and get more
influence and reach to influence more
people
the difficult balance 100 yeah 100 um
and I think a lot of people just in this
specific scenario like I want you guys
to think imagine like I would not want
someone recording me while I'm praying
until we like to be completely honest
with you I don't even know if you knew
he was being recorded and I think it's
probably better if he didn't know just
because all I mean I would I I'd dislike
being recorded during slow down or
anything like that just because I feel
like it plays with your intention like
subconsciously
um but
like internal weird for those of you who
pray eight or maybe even 20 like
especially if you've been working or
you've been to school all day and then
you just had a thought you just like
you're kind of in a food coma a little
bit and then you're standing there
praying like it's exhausting man it is
very very exhausting
so
I don't
I want you guys to
like when you look at this video please
just don't
don't try to like disrespect him in any
way or
say anything out of pocket just
at the end of the day like like we're
all human and we're all gonna like like
we're gonna get exhausted we're gonna be
tired if it's gonna be late at night and
we're standing there our legs are gonna
get tired our mind might we might lose
our whole shoe out for a little bit
it happens to all of us we're all human
and it's something that we all need to
work on so don't think that
um you're better than so and so and
just work on your focus on yourself and
inshallah make do out for the rest of
the old man inshallah inshallah
absolutely right bro and at the end of
the day like I mean just the stay alone
I think as a whole is is very very sad
and it's because people lack the basics
like these seven conditions of joking
believe it or not this is not advanced
stuff this is this is basic this is
something you as a Muslim are required
to know if you want a joke okay you as a
Muslim you're obligated to go and search
this stuff out
am I allowed to joke yes in certain
aspects in certain regards what are
those certain regards X Y and Z there
are seven specific and they're not
they're not they're not hard to be
honest and if you can become a master
kind of of that craft then you'll be
like you know Halal jokes are it'll be
okay do you think the processor never
you know made jokes or laughed or had
fun there are narrations of him joking
there are actual narrations of him
joking and there are narrations in which
for example he was on a camel with one
sahabi and they both fell off the camel
across the Sun was laughing at himself
was laughing at himself because he fell
you know some people they fall in public
they take themselves so seriously so
they get mad they get frustrated they
lose their mind he laughed about it
another time as a hobby he shook like a
tree and a bunch of like stuff from on
top of the branches fell down on the
process and you know like imagine
getting like you know water dropped on
you and like you know you go through a
little bit of a shock and some people
get really angry at that stuff which
maybe they can Aloha Adam you know I
don't have a problem with it but
Professor something he laughed at
himself when things like that happened
so joking is okay it's just in in the
regard that you do it in but even with
his wives you know he would always be
playful and cheerful and it was never
that serious except when it did but he
knew how to like turn that off and be in
a default state of not not taking
everything too seriously bro always
being in the middle path
yeah yeah
um random by the way this is not this is
not planned but people are commenting
saying that sneako accepted islamico
converted to Islam
um and they're saying that it's on his
Twitter so I actually did want to put
this yeah
can you guys see uh my screen not right
now no sir
oh wait it's not added to the thing but
I needed to be managing the back end
inshallah if you don't mind
all right
Islamic Christianity have a lot in
common I would say the major difference
some weird stuff in your father the son
the Holy Spirit what the hell is the
Holy Spirit and then you grow up and you
take your first communion you're reading
the body of Christ and a cracker so this
is cannibalism why am I eating a cracker
what part of the body of Jesus is this
is this the toe part of Jesus it's his
body kids are drinking wine kids are
getting drunk It's the blood it's wine
why are we giving kids alcohol and
you're drinking Jesus's blood it's a
little satanic to be drinking a dude's
Islamic you know it's crazy by the way
the the the punches in the caption why
sneaker averted to a stem from
Catholicism so it's kind of like him
stating
that he reverted to Islam from
Catholicism you just said that right now
he posted that himself let me see it
yeah it was posted four hours ago it's
found a lot so that's awesome
we've been praying foreign
with him bro
part of me uh when did we do that stream
with him probably a year ago a year ago
yeah
bro you could tell his monster has been
there he's been it's just been it's been
a matter of time hamdullah so that's
really exciting that's a good I always
love seeing I think it's slam recently I
mean you guys probably know better than
me but it seems like a slam recently has
been just on the come up in terms of
like publicity and uh
like I guess influencers and stuff of
that nature just people like noticing it
and people talking about it more
it's been amazing I think any publicity
for the most part is a good publicity
um obviously with Islam it's a little
bit more you have to make sure that
they're not like go the false media and
stuff and like that but I think recently
people especially because everyone's
been wanting to be inclusive of
everything which is
obviously we don't agree with all of
that but most Islam has fallen into that
fold which that part I'm okay with of
people trying to they're people wanting
to learn more about Islam people have
been a lot more respectful I've noticed
that even at school just in public
people are a lot more kind and uh
they genuinely just want to learn more
about Islam so I've been really happy
seeing seeing what's been happening with
the publicity and more and more people
coming to Islam
100 and I mean you can kind of trace it
you know it was it does go back to when
Andrew take except that it's them and of
course
um there is a huge surge in people at
least being interested in Islam or
praising Islam and um sneak out to be
fair to him because I know he's uh he's
kind of big on this point
um he was looking to stammer he was
interested in Islam before Andrew take
converted
um so you know out of respect for him I
wanted to mention that but regardless
nickel welcome to Islam bless you
inshallah now that you're a Muslim that
let's get in contact with your brothers
and we'd love to bring you on the
podcast to talk about your journey insha
Allah in person this time
inshallah
so while I mean hamdullah that's
beautiful news um
in
kind of light of you know the the sneako
sphere and the energy sphere
nothing to show but a lot to say
Justin Tate has been
charged with kind of whole new
allegations they went from age
trafficking which I can't say the word
but it's people you know traffic and
um
uh organizing uh criminal gang and all
this stuff he went from those charges to
being charged with enticing violence
firstly and this is an ignorant question
I'm really asking what the heck is
enticing violence is it me like like
going like fight fight like what's
enticing violence is it calling for
people to like you know Riot I don't get
it to be honest and it went from by the
way I don't know what's going on with
with Andrew Tate if he's been charged
with anything or not because I don't
know if you've been vocal about that but
this is actually insane like they did an
investigation before it was like okay we
believe they're innocent because we have
not seen any evidence there's always
like a and this is what you know the
opposition to him would mention you know
you don't know what the police has
you don't know what the the event the
not the defense the prosecutors have
maybe they're building up a huge case
they've been hyping up this case for
freaking like a year now like although
since April so it's been a year they've
been building up a huge case that's why
they locked him up for so long into this
stupid preventative detention and then
after a year they have nothing so they
switch the charges can you believe that
just let them go at this point just take
the L and let them go you already look
bad enough bro just call us put it put
it to an end the fact that and I want
people to to understand how crazy it is
that they switch the charge
they did not believe he was guilty of
this to begin with they didn't yeah they
thought he was guilty of something else
and now all of a sudden he's guilty of a
whole other thing now okay maybe during
this huge investigation they found
something else but you're gonna tell me
after this huge investigation all they
found was the possibility that not
Andrew but Tristan was inciting violence
from traffic to inciting violence that
is crazy man
did they arrest them again or so no not
just George yeah they they went from
being um uh input into kind of like jail
and detention to Paul and house arrest
most arrests so they're still like
basically detained in a way but they're
just in house arrest now so
it's oh man it's crazy man it's
absolutely insane but alhamdulillah as
um a sister Fatima says here life is the
test Allah he tests us right yeah he he
decides
in the highest points in our life the
lowest points in our life our tests are
trials tribulations and Allah he says
when Allah loves the person he tests
them
because testing is a a kind of a virtue
to be honest um if you can get through
it it's a blessing because Allah to get
you to a better State now he mentioned
this before that he was put in jail he
was locked up and all he had was the
Quran so he read the Quran and even
Tristan ended up in the Quran
um and all that stuff alhamdulillah so
it might be a blessing you know that you
know that saying show me the man I'll
show you the charge like if you look
deep into anyone's past you'll find
something you'll find some dirt on him
and I remember Tristan Tate yesterday he
tweeted bro that
um essentially he made an analogy like
someone's gonna find
a typo like a spelling mistake on one of
my tax returns does this mean now I'm
gonna be arrested for tax evasion
you know what I mean like where do you
draw the line and they've they've done
nothing compared to the average person
from what it's from what's known right
because we as Muslims we got to go with
the evidence
but they're basically going to try to
find anything they can now
to just convict them of anything
baseless bro I think that people who are
not ignorant and the people who can
like are not blind basically they could
see what's happening like if you're not
dumb like you see what's happening
you're not
like you see what they're doing they're
trying their best to come up with
anything and everything and just
throwing these stuff out there and like
I said I think this is good I think this
is better for us I mean like for certain
people I think this is good it's showing
them like like look this is how bad this
is how much they're scared of us this is
how much they want to put us down
because they're scared of the truth
coming out just as usual whenever
something is the truth they always want
to hide it and I think this is part of
the reason here in our message of that
epic we had so many shahadas this year
it was in in it was insane alhamdulillah
I mean and everyone just was just like
like things just like everything else
wasn't making sense to them everyone
felt a gap everyone felt a little hole
in their life every nothing else was
making sense they like and they could
see what was happening around them so
I'm just like alhamdulillah I think like
people who aren't
dumb essentially
um and people who are actually opening
their eyes like they could see like
that they're clearly trying to hide
something they're trying to put these
people down which means that they're
scared of them and
obviously it's because of Islam
mm-hmm yeah yeah you see a lot of people
kind of mock the whole you know o Matrix
yeah Matrix did this Matrix did that you
know
um but at the same time Yanni like we
know there is a we know there is a state
obviously we know there's a deep State
we know that there is a an agenda there
is some type of agenda
um whether we agree with her or not it
exists the you know the countries as
individuals have goals right I'm not
saying that there is one group of people
running like the entire Globe sorry my
light just died I wondered what happened
but I guess this is raw me after dark
now so it's getting serious we're
talking about serious things man The
Matrix is after me alhamdulillah but but
seriously there there is um
a state agenda just look at something
that's more clear if you don't want to
use anjutan example no problem let's
look at Julian Assange or Assange I'm
not sure
sorry I just um
heard someone says
I'm sorry I
how do I leave this call my bad I was in
I was in Discord which by the way for
the Discord uh call and show you got to
go to the three Muslim Discord the link
should be in the description uh if not
someone can share in the chat inshallah
gotta join there swipe down I'll show
you guys in a moment you'll find the
call and show section you can join in
the waiting room you will be vetted by
our vetting experts alhamdulillah before
being brought on inshallah but
regardless back to the main point look
at like Julian Assange
here's the person who founded Wikileaks
and through Wikileaks they released
official documented footage from the
military of the military American
Military doing horrendous things in um
in the summer in the Middle East
actually
and
it's truthful footage it's proper
evidence and it shows how corrupt some
parts athletes of the military are
now when this was released did America
say you know it's our fault we're gonna
reprimand these soldiers and make sure
that there are proper consequences
dishonorably discharged and all that
stuff no
did they give any indication that they
regret what happened in the slightest
snow all they said was okay that's it
we're gonna extradite Julian Assange
from the UK even though he's a I think
an Australian citizen
all the way to the US just so we can
throw him in our jails for up to like
174 years
are you gonna say that there's not a
deep State
um agenda being pushed that you cannot
even now criticize the military after it
violates his own international law that
it uh that it signed on
and that it so strongly enforces and by
the way that's the whole reason they
were in the Middle East because of Human
Rights and then they go and violate
human rights in the Middle East and they
can't even hold themselves accountable
when other people try to they get thrown
in jail are you gonna say there's no
deep state
are you gonna say there's no like Matrix
or whatever trying to push his agenda I
think it's it's it's it's it's it's
crazy to be honest if you don't at least
found them or accept an idea of a deep
state in that sense
one of the most common shaming tactics
bro that I hear is conspiracy theorists
just being thrown out there
what do you mean like they'll call us
conspiracy theorists for pointing out
plain facts bro
like commonsensical to me you know even
like me and Rami were talking about in
the Stream where there was Matt Walsh
debating uh a trans EMT and he I forgot
what he said he said that
he has like a basic question and then
the trans person was like what makes
someone a woman like what is a woman and
he was like an adult female and everyone
was clapping and then Rami was basically
making a point that like the bar is so
low that that's something completely
commendable just stating what a female
is in the 21st century
that is crazy Bismol bro yeah yeah yeah
it's crazy man it's a crazy world to be
living but alhamdulillah Islam is the
truth I mean I think at least in all of
this people can can see that Islam is is
so appealing now because Islam is the
antidote to all the stuff Islam is is
anti-all these crazy crazy weird
movements it's anti
pardon me extreme red pill or red pill
you know altogether it's anti-feminism
uh extreme feminism maybe feminism
altogether it's anti
um anti-crazy liberal
anti-socialism anti-capitalism it's
anti-everything because it's in the
middle it's the best way to live life it
instructs you
to live life in the best possible way
and not just for individuals but for the
state to run Society you know in Islam
the Khalifa The Leader is supposed to be
someone who was loved by the people and
he's supposed to be someone who loves
the people he's actually supposed to be
basically working for the people you
know if um
let's say a dead a deadbeat father
nowadays runs away from his his um Wife
and Kids it moves to a different country
the country that they live in currently
like America or Canada they're not going
to you know help take care of this woman
because in her kids because the bread
when it ran away like a soy boy
they're not going to do that they're
going to say oh that sucks okay anyways
and let you deal with it yourself
islamically there's a certain level of
obligation that the Khalifa himself that
the state has to take care of people
like that because we set proper uh roles
and we take into account social aspect
and real you're real just real life bro
in America they want to pretend that
there is not a social aspect of living
they want to act like there's just a
political side and then uh we'll just
forget about everything else you guys do
the rest socially why is there not like
a social governance there needs to be
some kind of social accountability in
Social governance
um but they don't want to they don't
want to apply that so that's why we've
gotten to this point where with the the
LG TV group uh pushing whatever they
want to push and side note this is
random but I really think there is a
p-e-d-o agenda I genuinely believe that
there is that agenda if you look at like
the the queer theorists the original
ones all of them wrote about this one of
them referring to it as being uh like a
taste for a spicy food imagine how
disgusting that is these are like the
founders of like queer Theory and all
that stuff
what does
the Q stand for
that thing
that exact thing queer subhanallah like
it's absolutely disgusting and now
people these same people by the way that
support this movement want to come and
say oh the prophet son he he married
Aisha when she was six and uh so on and
so forth it's like they have no
standards at all they will look at a man
1400 years ago who took care of someone
who hits you know adulthood at their
time and call them the most egregious
things even though he was the best man
to live and people like Michael Hart
recognized this
but when it comes to the same people
they support they have no problem
it's upon a lot man it's crazy we can go
on for days about it but
it is crazy yeah Islam is the antidote
to all that alhamdulillah thank God for
us now bro just imagine if we didn't
have Islam how lost we would be bro
would it be like these actually Crazy
Ones actually that's something I think
about all the time I just don't even
know
I look at this especially when I go on
like campus I'm just like bro like how
are these like who when these people
like wake up like what do they believe
their purpose is I just genuinely get so
confused I'm like what do you what
motivates you like is this money like it
has to just like
and
I think when you see like a convert like
how did that we were all born with it
but it's a different blessing when when
you revert back later on later on in
your life and you get to see it because
like these people genuinely had a hole
in their life and then they were able to
fill it so they know like what it was
life like on both sides I'm the love for
us we were never on the other side
um
that's why Islam is the greatest enema
that we can have alhamdulillah
beautifully said you know subhanallah
I want to share an experience I had I
think it was yesterday honestly I don't
even remember it was yesterday two days
ago and um the reason I'm mentioning is
because what you said Jad that you know
people with no Islam like imagine what
kind of Life they have
um I had experience yesterday where I
genuinely thought I was going to die I
swear to God I genuinely thought I was
gonna die
I um
um it was around Federal time yesterday
Okay so
um just a little bit before Fajr I went
for a walk you know late at night it was
it wasn't too cold it was a little cool
out I went for a walk
and this is how crazy it is it has
nothing to do with another person or
another being or another animal nothing
it was just me I was going for a walk
and I saw a Vegeta came in and I'm okay
I'll stay out a little bit longer though
so I'll go home for pleasure
it was like the sun came up so quick bro
the sun it was like the sun came up like
that bro I swear time went by like crazy
and then I'm like bro the sun looks like
it's up because it always looks like
it's up before it's fully up yeah
um
and I saw I'm like I need to go home I
started walking home I started to feel
really really sick like really nauseous
I felt like I was gonna throw up
and on top of that I felt very very weak
like 10 seconds later and then on top of
that I felt very dizzy and like you guys
might say this is basic it was basic I
didn't think it was anything crazy I'm
like oh this sucks I have to walk home
like this but whatever it was like maybe
five minute walk
and then
on top of that it got worse and worse so
I'm like I can't even walk so I sat down
on a bench I wasn't getting better I
wasn't getting worse I'm like okay like
now's the time for me to try and go make
a home I get up
I start walking
and the things start to go black you
guys know when you're editing an iPhone
picture and like you put Shadows all the
way up so everything's like all the
black yeah right that's how it felt
except the black was getting bigger and
bigger and kind of taking up everything
I could see so I could barely see
anymore
and this is where I'm like okay I might
pass out but I'm like at least like if I
pass out you know the sun's coming up
either someone will find me and I'll
wake up like either in a hospital or
I'll wake up here on the pavement that's
good that's crazy I couldn't even pull
up my phone I couldn't see anything so
I'm like
okay if I pass I'll be fine
and then the craziest freaking thing
happened
you guys know
when you're talking to a mic and a
speaker plays your voice back in real
time how you can hear yourself
externally
I could hear my own voice I like it
externally like my mouth's like I have
two miles right here and they're talking
I did not take any drugs I swear to God
I don't do that stuff I didn't do
anything bro that's crazy I I and I
literally asked myself like what the
heck is going on I swear to God because
of that I thought I was gonna die
everything is like black I can barely
see I feel super sick and I'm hearing
myself
I made so much stuff for Allah to
forgive me I'm like Allah's gonna take
me before I even make it for Fajr or
right when I just missed Vegeta because
I thought I missed it even though I
didn't hamdad ended up making it that
day I just I'm like at this point I just
have to try and walk home
I kept walking home and asking a lot to
forgive me and stuff and then after
maybe a few minutes of that it went down
I got better alhamdulillah and it was a
scariest experience in my life so the
reason I shared this the reason I shared
this is imagine if I didn't have Islam
imagine if I didn't believe in Allah if
I didn't believe it I didn't believe in
God I didn't believe in afterlife I'm
like 18 years of struggling and whatever
whatever
18 years 22 years bro I don't know what
day I'm living 22 years of working and
struggling all this stuff and
just like that it's all over because
I don't know like subhanallah
that is crazy
that is that is a crazy experience yeah
it humbled me though man I'm not less
than a wake-up call it's always good to
have things yeah every once in a while
just remind you that at any given moment
you can go so I think it's definitely
bro we sell humble to everything I had
something similar in Saudi arami knows
about it it was a dream it wasn't really
in real life but these things in the
moment might seem kind of weird and kind
of shocking and catches us off guard
and Miller make it easy for you around
me bro I hope nothing's wrong with your
health and I mean it'll make it make it
easy for you but
alhamdulillah bro because when you come
out of it
there's there's a Hadith around me if
you can do can you can you mention it
where the Prophet saw him talks about
you know like about the state of the
believer yeah yeah he said amazing is a
state of a Believer because anything
that happens to them is good if it's
given goodness like let's say they're
given like money or something like that
and they're grateful uh they're grateful
to Allah that is better for them and if
they're tested and something difficult
happens to them then they're patient and
that's better for them
so I only share that because Yani this
life is nothing but a temporary delusion
as Allah says in the Quran
and
I mean think about it man the only real
let's let's say there's a life after
this and that life is is more important
than this one
this life is nothing literally this life
is nothing because that life is the real
life this is literally a delusion
because it's deluding you from the
reality of what's to come next you know
imagine there's an army coming from over
the hill to come and like destroy your
people and stuff
and you see me sitting there playing
video games
you can be like listen there's an
inevitable attack coming your way right
now and you're not preparing you're not
running you're not fleeing
you're sitting here playing video games
and I'm like yeah bro like this I'm
really consumed in this right now you
know like maybe when they come here I'll
talk to them and we'll talk it out you
know
you'd look at this person okay you're
deluded there's no helping you you know
you deserve what's coming to you by
you're gonna take your family and run
away be a normal human being
that is what this life is like except
it's just 80 years long
and it's gonna go by very fast by the
way I promise you it will go by very
fast you're gonna wake up one day and
it's gonna be you're gonna be 60 years
old and be like what the heck you're
gonna wake up one day you're gonna have
health problems you're gonna be like
what the heck you're gonna wake up one
day and your family members are gonna be
dead you're gonna be like what the heck
man and then you will die one day as
well and you will wake up in the day of
judgment Allah will hold you accountable
so let's take the time to make God
inshallah before we move on to the
calling show
s
forgive us for our shortcomings and
grant us our good days on a day of
judgment Allah allow us to be good
righteous Muslims for his sake alone may
Allah purify our intentions may Allah
teach us his Deen and allow us to teach
it to those who are righteous and Pious
and those who seek out Islam Allah
always keep us guided to the straight
path and again may Allah forgives for
our sins and not hold us accountable on
the day of judgment Allah protect us
from the punishment of this life of the
grave and of the Hereafter and of the
Hellfire may Allah
increases in all things hair and grant
us good healing good risk and grants
Muslim success in this life in the next
all right alhamdulillah now let's move
on to something a little um a little
nicer inshallah
if you did not join e3m Discord then
join the t3m Discord
let me pull it up right here you guys
can see it but I can't there we go
so if you go to the t3m Discord you
click on it you're going to see this
page up here you're gonna have to verify
it takes a few seconds don't worry and
then if you scroll down you're gonna see
t3m call and show it's like the third or
fourth folder
you feel free to suggest your topic
ideas by the way any videos any links
any topics Charlotte here we have some
brothers
um already sharing things may Allah
bless them all and we already have
people in the waiting room and people in
the vetting room as well so
I'm gonna go ahead and join this
Insha'Allah and I'm going to unmute
myself and I'm gonna drag
one of our mods in here inshallah it's
not like them to me I'm sorry bro I
stole you you're on the air right now
can you hear me
okay can you guys hear to me
it's a little bit low
oh I think it's playing from my
I think it's playing for my um my mic
that might be why
because he's pretty loud on my end
it didn't sound like it was coming from
the screen
the screen no okay no it's your life
this doesn't work because we didn't have
enough time to prepare it shallow but I
have one other thing prepared but we'll
try a little bit inshallah so to me bro
do you have any ideas for how I can uh
set up the audio
[Music]
get your desktop app whatever your your
desktop app
okay how does it sound now did
could you guys hear him for a second or
no
it comes to speak
sorry John what to tell him to speak
real quick
to me can you say something bro
still the same thing
did you guys hear that
same as it's the same it's the same
instead of weekend someone said we can
hear him well enough
I just want to make sure people can hear
because you know we don't want to do a
college show if no one you know can hear
them yeah guys letting everyone in the
comments just say real quick if you can
hear tamim or not
okay
no worries inshallah first let me fix
this
okay talk again
can you guys hear okay people are saying
I can hear fine low low it's okay never
mind I take that back everyone else is
like it's too low it was cool technical
when he said hello or no
we're not hearing him though
God I can't hear you whenever maybe
whenever you're doing the like whenever
you're sharing a YouTube video or
something like we're hearing it fun so
right now it's not like it's it doesn't
sound like it's sharing the uh
the Discord it's it's like it's not
you're not sharing the audio it seems
like
I see I see
hmm
so there's no option to share there's an
option to share it um to share the audio
except for if I do a Chrome tab so you
know what let me log into
uh Discord on
I tried to do that bro but I'm logged
out of Discord I think because you
logged in
uh so I'll just let you do it or really
like we can have multiple accounts oh
yeah we did the thing
yeah yeah
[Music]
I feel like you know what I was gonna
say bro yeah
oh I did uh I have a 2fa that's why
um you can log in well shout out to my
mods bro uh or our mods come to that
they're really really doing good work
man
's like shout out to my mom sounds like
a streamer bro shout out to Mama are we
not streaming man yes sir
okay
there we go I think I think I'm getting
it now I think I'm getting okay okay
almost there
just be patient inshallah okay take a
breath I'm almost there it wasn't the
guy
okay it's not like a bro can you hear me
all right so tamim can hear me we can
hear him right now hopefully you're
sharing it oh you can hear him or no we
can't we can't not yet not yet okay I'm
not I'm not sharing yeah okay how about
now can you guys see the screen but
you're not sharing yet
I'm not sharing it okay wait I need to
go on streamer mode so give me one one
second
I hope you can do that on here man enjoy
appreciate you I know I didn't have time
to clean it up
where are you located at bro
Belle is right next to Epic measure
these Plano Islamic Center oh okay okay
so you're in Texas you're sorry sir what
about you
I'm near Toronto in a city called
Mississauga
Rami you there too
um nearby I'm in Niagara Falls you used
to live in Mississauga though yeah okay
there's so many people in case so many
Muslims in Canada it's actually crazy
bro so many Muslims in Texas bro I asked
you I'm not a Liars
but like a lot of people I speak to like
content creators and stuff like that
they're all every time I ask them where
they're from everyone just says Canada
let me let me ask you this bro because
in Canada we have a lot of halal food
options so how's it looking like in
Texas well Dallas to be fair Dallas does
have but like I think Dallas is unique
like Dallas is oh it's an exception it's
not like that all around the US Dallas
has so many Muslims
normally I don't think it's I wouldn't
say it's like the on the regular
zooming in yeah
um I know there's an option to have it
on the same like level as us I don't
know how to do that though
oh you're saying like the same size
yeah
it was okay the thing on the side with
three of us on the side and the screens
there yeah it was better
okay one second we're gonna we're gonna
figure this out guys please have some
silver yeah
yeah this is the first time
by the way around me are you streaming
the desktop or are you sure you can hear
it this is good this is good you can
hear it yeah you heard that right fed
yeah it was clear
okay okay
hello yeah okay yeah we're good we're
good
boom there we go that's what I wanted to
do that's it
see man
cut off nice well done around me
um or at least my name
I don't know I think I got to edit the
thing maybe but uh okay that's not our
biggest problem right now it doesn't
matter yeah it doesn't matter what you
think
it doesn't matter so tamim can you hear
them that's the main question
uh no I can't hear if you want we could
join the calls I could join the call if
you want is it possible for them to join
the yes yes that's a that's a good idea
please do that yeah but then
on here
waiting area I can drag you in yeah okay
oh we're gonna meet ourselves on this
thing okay yeah yeah if I can you uh can
you join the the Discord just go down to
the waiting room and then I'll drag you
in give me one sec on my laptop or on my
phone I'm in the waiting area laptop is
best
hey I can hear you
Romney you hear me
uh let me mute you here one sec oh
you're already muted yeah I can hear you
okay okay we're doing it man we're doing
it we're getting there shortly you want
me to log into my Discord or you want me
to log into the TVM Discord your Discord
your Discord I'll try to remember bro
inshallah
okay inshallah
only rami's beard could be called oh
well never mind bro that's not true man
a beard is a beard
alhamdulillah
it will I go if don't worry inshallah
we're gonna
[Music]
thank you Yousef benassa
will optimize in the future so it's a
little bit smoother inshallah
urine
I'm in bro what do I do there you go
there you go there you go so go to the
three Muslim server to scroll down to
the like the call-in show section and
then click the waiting room
join the waiting room
let's suggest how tall are you
um
fixed three
call and show I don't see it bro
it's a quick winning area
I see support reception info
yeah
if you go to the very top you'll see
um
oh yeah so you're at like verify support
reception info scroll down under
community and
um under realest podcast you'll see it
says t3m call and show just click on
waiting area
oh wait
3M waiting area yep I see it okay there
we go
what the heck is a lot of people in
there
we got fans man I'm just kidding
wait why is
it because uh you're gonna have to so
you have to mute in the should I click
join voice
um yeah join join voice inshallah
dragon from America
if I had Street I've heard Mew in US
stream yard yeah and then you're gonna
probably wanna
if you were echoing just mute Us in uh
Discord or right click on us and click
mute
because you're hearing is probably on
both
well you're muted on stream here so he's
not hearing you on both but maybe me oh
yeah you're the only one yeah yeah
okay are we good now everyone can hear
everyone turn it back and where he's
he's back and waiting on you why why did
somebody banish him bro I'm bringing him
back
okay can everyone hear everyone
I keep getting getting kicked though
um who's moving you
yeah
bro it's like three times though okay
it's okay if I start bringing in people
in uh there's some brothers I've been
waiting for yeah yeah let's let's bring
some people why does he keep getting
moved
I don't know to me do you know what's
happening yeah I'll uh
I'll change it
Discord just doesn't like him too much
it's okay
I don't think I don't think he likes
Discord too much either
you're muted right now man
we're gonna hear you sing me talking in
the Discord they can't hear me
no yeah I can hear you okay now now we
can okay
so meet yourself on stream yard and then
there we go okay say something fired
okay let's verify everyone can hear
everyone right you guys can hear it
comments you're good I'm Judd tamim can
you say something
hello
hey yo oh no there's always something
man let me let me see bro we lost half
the viewers
I'm surprised everyone except maybe 30
people State yeah yeah
alhamdulillah
okay probably not guys patience patience
we're basically basically basically
there just give me one second
yo Judd are you a gamer bro
[Music]
um
I barely kind of
what do you play
I Dibble dabble yeah
what do you play I don't play anything
though bro but I feel like you're a
gamer I could tell Loki Loki
but
yo this guy's just spent a lot of time
nowadays you know what I'm saying
I don't want I don't want the I don't
want them in the viewers thinking you
play games
no no of course not bro
all right let's bring the first uh
caller in inshallah
to me okay inshallah I'll drag them in
shallah bro why am I in the waiting area
again you're not you're not you're not
oh it just says waiting area no no no
you're good don't worry okay
good
um
all right what brings you to the stream
bro why is it that going bro
honestly I think I was just playing the
live stream sorry about that
no Romy you're a queen too um just mute
me on Discord it should be fine this
code okay yeah
all right
so
okay come on give us give us your
thoughts on um uh the let's go with the
abutemia situation were you here for
that
uh uh it's like
oh okay I heard a little [__]
so why did you want to jump on the call
today
I can give my thoughts on the epidemia
situation inshallah yeah all right so
when I go for it
so the situation not with Damia a great
great brother for us of course he's done
a lot for the unless he's been sitting
so many of us young Brothers including
myself I am not really kind of what that
situation tells
we have to assume in the best of our
brothers and sisters and Islam and that
video is a contradiction of that
practice like clearly the brother was
traveling the brother was cranky I'm
praying while traveling I personally
know from experience that's not fun at
all trying to stay up especially in The
Last Broadcast just doing anything you
can to not fall down fall asleep
completely hard and I don't understand
why any I'm not trying to be rude or
anything to any of our brothers but I
don't really understand the logic and
portraying one of our really good
brothers that is benefiting the owner in
such a way that's my two cents on the
topic in general yeah
for joining we don't have long because
we had a bit of a late starts inshallah
we're going to bring someone else up
okay
inshallah
right clicking
time
the sky is clearly the energy fence
don't like them
nah it's because I'm very like tired
that's why I've been in the jail for a
bit long I just came out of the house
arrest so yeah wow
yeah I don't have any questions but I've
been watching you guys a lot like over
the years and I wanted to see you Mike
thank you guys for your weekend for the
Muslim um and keep going and then you
guys will reach many brothers and
sisters across the world and may Allah
make everything easier for you guys
inshallah I mean I mean
what a great brother inshallah
to return to UAE from Romania
all right it's not going to have a lot
another uh pretty bougie profile picture
uh what do you mean by that um all right
I'm joking
Yusuf bro I know it was you kicking me
out of the room do I exposed my sins bro
relax
my bad I'll just say something like like
one thing that I like I didn't I don't
really see like social media or like
just like personalities talking about
like educate specifically is that like
like I know a lot of people say like
okay he did all these bad things like
even if it wasn't a moment of jahedia
like you still shouldn't like like doing
these certain things Phil says about
your character but like then you bring
up the like
how like objective versus like I think
people understand like the objective for
the subjective morality like I'm like
how like what's it called I'm actually
waffling right now but like I can't
explain this listen to words I
understand what you're saying basically
what you're saying is once a lot of
people once someone has maybe converted
to Islam or maybe they were always
Muslim but they had like a turn in their
life for a time where they flipped the
page basically and and a lot of people
still bring up their past and they don't
let them forget it and
that's something that we as Muslims as
the Muslim Community we should never
bring up someone else's past especially
if they haven't tried to improve
themselves or if someone who was a
Christian or whatever and they converted
to Islam or reverted to Islam
that we should never remind them of the
sins that they used to do that's not
something that we as Muslims are
supposed to do especially if this person
is trying obviously they're trying to
forget that they don't want to remember
that time of their life at the time when
they were disobeying Allah and weren't
being the best version of themselves so
I agree with you I think that's what you
were trying to say hopefully yeah like I
will try to say something else but like
that was tough
you said bro I know you're a troll I'm
not a troll bro okay I think I know what
you're trying to say I mean there's only
so many routes you could take with the
topic of subjective and objective
morality subjective is just based on
whatever you know an individual or you
know a group of people think or feel and
that's going to change based on the
person based on the group and objective
is something that is true no matter what
for example one plus one equals two
that's true no matter what no matter
what um the freaking mathematics
Department
um it says because there was actually
one Department trying to say that one
plus one does not equal two anymore
because it's actually affiliated with
some some weird supremacist group so I
don't know what oh my God
I swear you guys can look it up I'm not
you guys can look it up on your own
accord I don't want to ruin brain cells
today but yeah yeah
like basically like without God you
can't blame someone for what they did
oh you're talking about determinism
I'm saying in general if they don't have
a gun in their life you can't like
what's it called like they did like
right and wrong in their life that like
is it relevant at that point
because it's like I don't know about
that bro
I I don't understand I should tell black
spinning but like basically no I get
your point I'm saying I don't know if if
I agree with that or not really why do
you think if somebody doesn't have God
in their life that they're not they're
basically absolved from all
responsibility you know I often
absolutely
what I'm saying is like at that point
like if they really think about their
lives like if you're an atheist if
you're a nihilist or whatever right
right like what like right and wrong
like basically it means not it should
never should mean nothing to you at that
point
so are you saying are you saying in your
eyes then uh blameworthy no I think they
are blame I think they are blameworthy
because they don't have God in their
life that's what that's what's Liam
worthy so they don't have they don't
have these sets of morals to follow but
I'm just saying like if you don't if you
don't believe God exists or whatever
like you can't you can't say what's
right or what's wrong so you can't blame
Andrew for what he did because he didn't
believe in or right or wrong at that
moment in his life oh okay right it's
very understandable I see him well I
mean let's let's take a second let's say
when you say you can't blame him for
what he did or what are you talking
about what did he do
um I think that's a big question you
know yeah
I see I mean listen anything anything
that's Haram anything that's Haram we
denounce no matter what no matter who
did it yeah
um and um all that stuff I think the
issue here is that there's no evidence
that he did anything and it's more clear
because I I as far as I know don't call
me as far as I know they've dropped the
whole like H human yeah yeah you know
um traffic violation thing
yeah yeah so but yeah but I mean bro if
you don't yeah sorry for interrupting
bro I don't know if you you're the one
that's streaming right like you're
sharing the stream yeah can you click on
yusuf's thing so it's just him showing
on stream yard
I was trying to violate my profile
picture
you like my cut
it's nice bro but it doesn't make the
cut
all right all right I've been here for
too long all right appreciate y'all take
care
all right let's bring in the next guest
let's put these names and profile
pictures else I like them bro on the
internet you have to be conspicuous
um earlier with the guys I was chatting
and they were talking they're telling me
you know what kind of topics should we
talk about one of the topics that I
think is very important is streaming I
know earlier you were giving Jabs to
Fayette about like you know Fed was like
saying oh you're a streamer now actually
I think it's a very very important topic
and the reason is because today I'm I'm
a guy who enjoys watching streams and
watching streamers and I usually watch
streamer clips
so one of the clips a popular streamer
was playing valorant and one of the kids
he was playing with he's like he says
like I don't watch Chris anymore because
he transitioned and all that and I don't
want to watch Mr Beast because my dad
told me so okay and the streamer the
entire game is telling me no no your dad
is backwards don't listen to your dad
right yeah and so I think that is an
issue that we have within our society
right now is that
you have kids growing up right they're
playing these games they're watching
these streamers
and they're gonna get exposed to these
kind of things and so my question is how
come we don't have
exemplary streamers you know
um God bless Gamers I'm not gonna say
the other one who are actually you know
in the space and they're like opposing
this and they're like no no no these are
traditions this is what you should stand
up for long is wrong
right
um so I wanted your thoughts on like
what do you think about something like
that I mean if you missed my streams
that much man that's all you have to say
and I'll be back inshallah next week
to be honest you're a wonderful person
but this is the first time I've seen you
okay
no I'm I'm gonna be I'm seriously
I would love to see Someone Like You on
the top stuff like on the top pay to
Twitch like oh Jed streaming whatever
it's shallow one day man
don't don't forget no that someone can
be not known in the Dunya but how much
they mentioned by Allah to the angels
it's true but like you should be but God
doesn't say you should walk the Dunya
and like
they're gonna be useless
but understand like Fame is a necessary
evil so if you have the right near and
you know why you're trying to level up
and have more eyes on you and you do
something with your platform
yeah yeah but no the brother makes a
good point brother I I agree 100 the
Muslims should be the top of everything
I know the number is not going to want
me to say that I'm going to say the
Muslim should be the top of everything
you know I'm I'm using this as a general
example um the things things like UFC
and that stuff it is actually Haram
um uh I don't know about watching per se
but I will say at least participating in
it you're fighting and punching the face
and that stuff for money and there's
like you know ringside women all that
stuff with a lot of them
we love Habib yeah yeah and but exactly
thank you for stealing my point uh you
know we love we do love Habib you know
he's the top of the the game there and
people are going to come at me and say
no it's not the best okay you know what
I'm saying move leave
um he beat McGregor he smashed him
alhamdulillah you know he smashed your
boy
um
yeah yeah yeah and also another thing
speaking of streamers I saw a video of
you the other day you were talking about
Hassan [__] yeah
um if you can remind me what were you
like talking what was that what was he
ranting about he was basically saying
that he's losing his mind about Andrew
Tay he's saying that you taste like a
fake Muslim and all that stuff and uh
okay okay okay yeah yeah so so now I
remember her son [__] in one of his
prominent podcasts here and I think it
was the not the most recent one the one
before he himself with his own tongue
confessed that he is not Muslim he said
that yes and what Hassan [__] does more
often than not whenever it's convenient
for him in an argument is to flip the
Muslim card because he grew up Turkish
and a Muslim
I again
I have I heard it myself and there have
been receipts before of him saying like
you know what I grew when I was in
Turkey I was in third grade and they
were telling me about Islam and I didn't
believe it and blah blah blah and and so
I decided not to to to to be Muslim yeah
bro you're actually right because even
on Instagram bro I see pictures of him
wearing nail polish and stuff and then
in the caption it says this is my year
inshallah what you know you know he he
reacted to the Jubilee video he started
making fun of me because I'm because
yeah did you ever see that yeah yeah
he's a weird person I I think bro
honestly I think he was just shocked to
find out that Andrew Tate is actually
more Muslim than him or possibly more
Muslim yeah I would love to talk to
honestly yeah you're right I would love
to talk to the guy I'm gonna be honest I
would I would really love to talk to the
guy because one of two things is going
to happen right either he'll come back
to Islam and accept it or he'll expose
that he's either a hypocrite or he's
he's a non-muslim it'll come out he'll
be forced to stop using that card once
he you know if yeah yeah the thing is
what I'm going to say is that he always
flips the Muslim card whenever it's
convenient in the argument like he's a
full-blown leftist and he uses the
Muslim card it's his no no it's his it's
his I'm a minority card yeah
you know what I'm saying you know the
alphabet Community you see a lot of
white people joining the alphabet
Community why so that they can flip the
I'm a minority card I I'm the minority
you can't say this about me you can't do
this to me blah blah but most of the
time it's just it's whatever yeah
again I'm not gonna go into people's
like in a way yeah but to me and I've
I've watched his son like I've watched
the song way way way back when he was
still friends with Destiny for those of
you watching and know the Lord know the
Lord but like again
and I feel bad for the God because like
I used to watch him and I was just like
you know Hassan she has good opinions in
certain issues especially the Palestine
issues some of these political takes are
pretty good but like this thing that
he's using Islam
when it's convenient for him it's got to
stop
and and that's what I'm saying we have
to have people in that Community
especially in the internet and God bless
you guys I mean you guys are still
starting hopefully inshallah maybe one
day you'll see me as well my YouTube
channel and and help you know hopefully
get as successful as you guys but like
we have to step up the game right like I
can't let my nephew or my brother or my
son talk to Clint Stevens about like how
transitioning is a good idea
right it's just it's not it shouldn't
happen right if he's gonna play video
games I have to be there and not only be
there I'm going to be carrying him
there we go
if you want Muppets yeah these are two
huge topics and if you want like Clips
to the um to the incident itself
um maybe I should add you if you'd like
add me I'm not gonna force myself on you
guys but like if you'd like I I know
Clips I have receipts
um but yeah yeah
video from you Romi and faiyan
do us a favor inshallah go to the uh the
suggestions tab it's it's somewhere in
the Colin show
um we might move it later and just post
whatever videos that we could uh or any
topics we can see it right now the mods
can link it to me that would be great
I'm grumpy monkas in uh in the Discord
all right there you go you heard of your
first putting growth months
all right let's bring inshallah I think
we'll do one or maybe yeah
and we'll wrap it up for the day
um our mods just disappeared on us I
guess okay there we go there we go
all right and who's gonna be the lucky
caller
imagine there's just no one left
all right here we go
uh
what brings you to the calling show man
I came here to uh ask what do you guys
think of this here are some new
conflicts
um
well okay I mean Define the conflict
what do you mean by that like
like what do you
like to take fear on them I see I see
um I'm gonna give a very generic
uh answer
um it is obviously definitely wrong to
assume that
um sunnis as a whole are are kuffar
that's completely wrong you mean she is
no I'm starting okay okay I'm starting
with this one I was so [__] I was
surfing
no no I'm starting with the Sunny Side
of talking to you yeah don't worry
there's there's two sides here let's
take a breath it is completely Haram to
assume that you know Sundays are all um
kofar or anything like that which is
what some of them maybe might believe
and it goes against the Hadith where he
says go with the majority of the Jamaica
and so on and so forth
and but it's also incorrect
to say all she has
because it depends on what they actually
believe
um that would take them out of the photo
Islam or not take them out of the follow
Islam that's generic but also I think
it's important that you understand the
history
of divide was a basically a political
dispute
that became theological to summarize it
and I asked myself about this and this
is what he told me as well it was a
political indifference that became a
theological one so they had a political
dispute and then they they changed the
theology to kind of fit what they want
that's why you hear all these stories
about you know and these stories about
Omar and Abu Bakr and all these people
the great sahaba that some of them you
know slander and libel and all that
stuff where Allah says in the Quran that
he's pleased with them
that I contacted they both said the same
thing to me that at the end of the day
when it comes to Shia you don't know if
the vast majority of shias are ignorant
or they know the truth and they assist
in arrogance so he said that you can't
make the fear on shias like in general
but you can unshere Scholars
I see I see well uh what about Ash
Harris
no no you guys are more informed on this
topic than I am you guys got Angela and
uh as my father as a chef my father
arrived he is very
against hasharies you know he sold me
about uh
yeah so this is with all due respect to
you and your father may Allah bless them
um I'm not a prayer I'm not a Sheikh I'm
not you know any anyone but I I this is
something I discussed with my teacher
and other people I'm not standing up so
the asharis are where the majority of
the scholars
majority of shafis are usheri and
there's another school of thought I
don't remember which one majority of
them are I think it might be Malik
majority of them are ashari Allah
regardless
what like what about it or about them do
you say is misguidance because a lot of
the time they come to the same
conclusion in terms of their their
but the way they get there is slightly
different and you will see certain
Hadith you know for example it was
either IBN abbasaur
who took the Ayah from the Quran he says
that everywhere you turn
you see the face of Allah
and this one's a hobby he said that this
is actually talking about the Qibla
you know so it's like a more like a of a
metaphorical thing now it seems like so
to say that Yani it's completely
incorrect to take an asharya stance on
these things it's completely incorrect
in and of itself most of the ummah from
even you know after like from the the
the uh I don't want to say about let's
say tabi and Tabitha you know majority
or maybe I shouldn't say that because
usherism kind of became a thing later on
but from that point onwards they were
were the majority of the ummah
so people you know Authority is coming
and saying or some people coming saying
that oh asheries are Miss God and all
these crazy things
you're going to say like
um you're gonna say they're completely
misguided and all the stuff like I I
actually think that you're not egregious
you know there's something right
the the attributes of Allah right
yeah like I'm not saying I agree with
this right but they're like saying uh
suffer about the hand of God and stuff
and like uh
some have come to the conclusion that
they are confirm because of uh
that they're not believing in some of
the attributes of God yeah so that's
yeah that's a misrepresentation of what
um the ashari position is and this
should not be an Arcadia discussion I'm
not super well versed in the in depths
of it but on a basic level and they will
not
um you know disagree with the eye in the
Quran Allah mentions like a hand or
something like that they will affirm it
and um they'll even say you know Yani
it's in a way that befits Allah that we
don't understand like the author you say
but the way they get to that conclusion
is different so like in Authority or
someone who claims me author you might
say you know Allah has the hand in a way
that befits him and someone might say uh
and actually might say it doesn't Allah
to have a limb so that's not what he
means and it's something a little more
metaphorical that yeah we don't exactly
understand so they get to the same
conclusion in two different ways
um and I think it's really really a form
of sectarianism to say that actually no
I know it's a form of sectarianism to
say that oh actually is misguided
because of this maybe there are actually
100 but to generalize all of them sorry
part of my camera I know it's a little
floppy right now but to generalize all
of them and say that they're all
misguided I think is it's crazy and I
don't want to I don't want to open this
dig you know a big hole here and because
I know it's a big topic for people and
there are sectarian people who would
like I hate this discussion but yeah the
truth is the truth inshallah
if you look at what some people say that
oh some usheris believe that you know
Hellfire is not Eternal or something
like that which I I disagree with as far
as not Hellfire is eternal just like
Jannah is eternal but at the same time
it not abutemia but
held the same belief he himself as an
author he held the same belief so I
think unfortunately a lot of people pick
and choose when it comes to this
discussion I think Allah knows best
listen if you are 30 no no worries
inshallah no worries
I think you're confusing
no you know no I I I okay well let me
repeat what I said and you can let me
know inshallah I said most some people
say that there are some that believe
that Hellfire is not eternal
Allah
who was an author he held the same
opinion
I was speaking about this uh there are
three bits of God you know yeah I know
I'm just I'm just because it kind of
Falls kind of in the same category of
how you interpret the
um the the descriptions on and so forth
you know because that's a part of our
you know Heaven and Hell all that stuff
what we believe but um regardless yeah
I'm not going to talk in depth about the
attributes of Allah I have not studied
in depth um to talk about it and I said
you know what I know and I don't want to
go beyond that Insha'Allah nor do I
think we should you know talk about
these things like like this if an usher
in utterly won a debate inshallah they
can go for that
but
um regardless I I think people should
educate themselves on this and really
look into the history to see what the
truth is because I think there's been a
lot of misinformation provided on this
but I get I get my answer mail and Allah
Knows Best
before you send me off
uh Europe
um that I'm Palestinian but I don't
speak Arabic well not fluent oh I see
yeah I've had the funny joke in my mind
it was a fun out of a joke
did you say it anyway if it's
appropriate yeah you know it in Arabic
it's a joke in Arabic it might be like a
pun or something I won't but I know
majority of the viewers that know Arabic
will find it funny
yeah
I don't know what it means
do you wanna do you want to explain it
yeah no jokes are not funny if you
explain it
means uh
to fly
and uh it means get a haircut at the
same time
but so like I said there's about that's
vault
because he like flew in there which
means uh Gaza said at the same time
I think it's one of those things that's
only funny in Arabic I don't know
judge rolling bro
[Laughter]
I like his energy bro yeah
I mean
uh all right should we do one more wrap
it up I think it's better that's it bro
let's wrap it up all right oh someone
was brought in so yo this one we'll give
you 30 seconds because we were actually
supposed to end this wow that is crazy
bring him back bring him back it's okay
he's gone bro it's not even the way to
give him anything he's like 30 seconds
nah I'm recording oh that's so funny man
that's hilarious okay there we go okay
next next time
guys for joining inshaallah
um
I think it was a good Stream So Logan do
more of this
um hopefully we'll have things figured
out beforehand so we don't have to
struggle a little bit but we kind of got
the Justified I think the Colin show was
a great uh addition and I would like to
get more people who actually disagree
with us each other so we can have more
fruitful discussions on that topic
um and with that being said any final
words brothers
for having me on it's always an honor
and I love the energy and being with you
guys so inshallah we can do this more in
the future
um
and that's that's it for me
Allah